[Music]
talking about Shawn he's 18 years old in
Pittsburgh independent on his own trying
to figure out how to get into college
you signed up for Penn State 18,000 a
year plus other expenses and he's ten
thousand short even after help he got
from here and there even after some
loans and for an aerospace degree is
that a fair summary of what you told me
so far sir yes sir okay cool so explain
to me I'm curious what you mean by
independent or how are you on your own
at 18 what's what's their circumstance
so recently in 2012 while nothing
recently my father passed and then last
within the past two years my mother
passed
unfortunately enough I was able to you
know get welcomed in the home of a
teammate I played with and uh okay they
obtained legal guardianship with me but
they're not in a position to where they
can help fund my college gotcha
I understand okay Wow all right and so
you're 18 and you graduate from high
school this year or last year odd this
year this coming May yes sir okay and
you were expecting to head into college
in the fall actually this summer I was
enrolled in summer sessions oh I see
okay all right and have you actually
obtained the loans or just signed the
documents so the only ones that have
been you know guarantee has been the
federal loans provided you know called
university loans you know through FAFSA
yeah so due to my situation you know not
many in my life are in a position where
they can cosign for me so really I have
a fair fair amount today top due to my
situation through Social Security and
whatnot and so my real question is well
it's not like I'm gonna go back just
walk with me here a minute I'm gonna
walk with you all right so FAFSA is not
alone FAFSA is an application that sets
you up for grants and other things and
sees if you're available for Pell grants
are you not available for a Pell Grant
no I have I have the summary written up
about 6000 for a Pell Grant yeah anybody
a state and so on
and then the actual loans that you have
to pay back or how much at this stage
for a subsidized loan they guarantee of
3500 don't print unsubsidized loan that
they guaranteed 6000 so approximately
approximately $9,500 okay have you have
not actually received that money but
you've signed the paperwork correct okay
all right trying to figure see what
stage we're in but you're signing up for
a tuition that's 18,000 a year and as
you said one of the more expensive
tuitions out there okay so aerospace is
what your goal is correct
alright and why I'm not saying it
shouldn't be I'm just curious it's just
what I've had a passion throughout you
know my young years and going through
high school I've taken a lot of classes
that have really refined my knowledge
and that and that's what I want to do
what do you want to do in aerospace tell
me what you're talking about as a career
more on the manufacturing side of this I
I've been I've been enrolled in classes
you know utilizing fancy technology and
you know I think you know going into
manufacturing regards the aerospace
would really be a good position for me
you know right okay
the way I answer questions shown on this
show when I went to college I was in a
similar situation my parent I was not my
parents were alive but it was up to me
to get through school okay and so I
worked and scratched and clawed
ridiculous stuff to get through school
and so I know how it feels to be right
where you are and what you're doing and
what you're studying and so forth so the
way I answer questions is if I was 18
and the 58 year old version which I am
of me could look back what would he tell
me or what would I tell you if I woke up
in your shoes but I know what I know
today okay okay now number one I think
you ought to study aerospace I agree
with that and I think you
like you've got a passion for it you
probably have a knack for it
you're obviously intelligent you're
articulate you're on a big-time radio
show you're carrying the conversation
you're not freaked out and then the
corner sucking your thumb you've got
some poise you've got a lot of positive
attributes that are going to carry you
through especially with all the things
you've been through with the loss of
your parents I'm so sorry for that but I
mean you're you're a young stud I'm
proud of you
the having said that I want you to go
about it in a way that when you're 30
you're not so far in debt you can't
breathe and you haven't said no matter
what the price no matter how dumb the
way I do it is I'm going to do this at
Penn State this way
and I think that's a mistake so what I
would do if I woke up in your shoes is I
would go full stop and I'd pull the plug
on Penn State you can't afford it it's
at your doorstep you're not ready you
don't have the money and there's not any
way we can get you the money with work
which is your only other source by the
time you need it all right now I'm not
saying pull the plug on it permanently
but I'm going to do at least one year at
a community college taking basic classes
that all transfer that are the
equivalent of my freshman year at Penn
State because you ain't taking no
aerospace in your freshman year dude
it's all it's all you know but boring
classes freshman year so it's core stuff
and probably your sophomore year so but
if you went somewhere that wasn't 18
thousand for the fot the coming 12 and
it didn't impede your progress towards
your goal because it all transfers but
it didn't cost you 18,000 it cost you mm
oh now we got a different world we're
living in and during that 12 months you
worked your butt off mowing grass
ubering delivering pizzas you work all
the time and you pile up the money to
enter Penn State
either in your sophomore year or your
junior year depending on how the money
piles up and depending on how well those
community classes Community College
classes match up with your you know I
want them to fully transfer I don't want
any wasted motion in the inefficiency
with the classes you take I want to take
six classes that don't turn over they
all need to apply to where you want to
go but I think by the time you get to
either your sophomore or a junior year
you can start piling up enough cash with
zero loans to work your way through this
thing with the Pell Grant and and work
your butt off and I you know it's 6,000
of the 18,000 you need $12,000 that's a
thousand dollars a month plus you need a
place to live where you gonna live
freshmen they're playing live in
dormitories okay all right so the
generosity of the family
you need to move on you're not gonna be
still you're not able to stay with that
family another year I believe so
I do have you know I have family and
relatives close by that I was offered
there and all services good okay camp in
their garage they know what and mow
their grass for rent okay and let's save
that dorm money because that dorm money
gets you aerospace degree from Penn
State the dorm don't buy your nothing
it's like living in a jail cell it's
concrete walls in a bad bed ain't
nothing sexy about it so one one thing I
do not feel like I said was I do have a
fair amount of money saved up throughout
my situation I've watched roughly forty
thousand dollars okay well I mean you
use that to supplement but I wouldn't
use these loans I would drop the loans
okay so it would it be a feasible plan
to supplement that ninety five hundred
this you know the savings and you know
work works throughout college and yep
they possibly apply for loans later
no I'm not gonna apply for loans I'm not
putting you in debt I want you to figure
out a way to cash flow this
by not living in the dorm by thinking
about it differently if you want to use
the 40,000 and go ahead and start I'm
with you let's do that
zero loans but here's what you want to
do you want to do a projection out
through the end of the four years to say
this is how much money I need above
40,000 and above Pell and that much
money you have to be able to earn and I
think you can do it I think you can do
it and but but don't go into debt and do
this with a plan
don't let this stuff happen to you you
happen to hit you call me back if I can
help you I'm I'm impressed with you I
hope anyway I can